(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Bom, nessa aula nós vamos falar sobre estratégias
de venda que você pode utilizar para aumentar
o seu lucro.
Primeira coisa que você deve lembrar, você comprou
o imóvel abaixo do preço de mercado, 40,
50% abaixo do preço de mercado, para
que você tenha um lucro expressivo, é importante
que você venda o mais rápido possível, afinal,
enquanto aquele imóvel está em sua propriedade, ele
gera custos como IPTU e condomínio mensal.
Qual é a primeira estratégia de venda que
eu sempre adoto?
É colocar o imóvel abaixo do preço médio
de mercado, eu calculo o preço médio de
mercado e esse cálculo eu faço antes de
arrematar, porque esse cálculo é importante para ver
a viabilidade financeira daquele imóvel, então eu já
sei qual é o preço médio daquele imóvel
e no momento da venda, eu aplico um
percentual de desconto entre 5% e 10%,
por quê?
Porque isso aí vai atrair maiores interessados no
seu imóvel, afinal, você está vendendo abaixo do
preço do mercado, é importante ter em mente
que comprou barato, vendeu barato e essa venda
barata não precisa ser uma venda absurdamente barata,
se você aplicar 5% de desconto de
acordo com o valor do mercado, já é
bem atrativo, já vai ter bastante visualização no
anúncio que você fizer e além disso, quanto
mais rápido você vender, menos gasto você vai
ter mensalmente para manter aquele imóvel como IPTU
e condomínio.
A segunda estratégia de venda que eu recomendo
que vocês façam é utilizar corretores de imóvel
para a venda do seu imóvel, por quê?
Porque esses são os profissionais habilitados para vender
o imóvel, eles vivem exclusivamente disso, a maioria
dos corretores de imóveis possuem uma grande rede
de relacionamento que pode abreviar em muito o
tempo necessário para a venda de um imóvel,
então toda vez que eu analiso um imóvel
de meu interesse para arrematar, eu já coloco
o valor da comissão do corretor na venda,
vocês podem ter verificado que na própria calculadora
que eu desenvolvi e disponibilizo aqui no curso
para vocês, ao final dela tem o valor
da comissão do corretor e aí você deve
adaptar a comissão do corretor que se aplica
no estado que você vai vender aquele imóvel,
existem estados que colocam 4% do valor
da venda, estados que colocam 5% do
valor da venda, estados que colocam 6%
do valor da venda, aqui em São Paulo,
por exemplo, o valor da comissão de corretor
é 6% da venda, então eu sempre
calculo já o lucro que eu espero ter
do imóvel abatendo o valor da comissão do
corretor.
Qual é a dica sobre o corretor de
imóvel?
Coloque no maior número de corretores que você
puder, se algum corretor vier com uma proposta
de uma cláusula de exclusividade, não aceite essa
cláusula de exclusividade, essa cláusula só é interessante
para o corretor, para quem quer vender o
imóvel de forma mais rápida, não é interessante
ter exclusividade com nenhum profissional ou com nenhuma
imobiliária, é importante que você coloque no máximo
de imobiliárias que você puder, porque todas essas
imobiliárias vão veicular propagandas daquele seu imóvel e
a chance de que o imóvel seja vendido
mais rápido vai ser ainda maior.
Nada impede que você contrate um corretor de
imóvel e também faça seu anúncio por conta
própria, hoje em dia a gente tem grandes
portais de vendas de imóveis, alguns exemplos deles
Viva Real, OLX, Zap Imóveis, Pra Alguns Andares,
Quinta Andar e Loft também realizam vendas de
imóveis e são bem conhecidas, então nada impede
que você coloque com um corretor, mas faça
seu anúncio de uma venda direta, tem bastante
gente que até prefere comprar diretamente com o
proprietário, porque assim pode chorar um pouco o
preço, afinal se for com o corretor, o
proprietário vai pagar a comissão dele, se ele
vender diretamente não vai ter comissão, então é
possível que o proprietário conceda um pouco de
desconto a quem está interessado a comprar aquele
imóvel.
Se você optar por colocar anúncios, façam anúncios
bem feitos, existem anúncios de inúmeros imóveis que
a descrição do imóvel é bem fraca, bota
só o básico, 3 quartos, uma suíte, sala
e cozinha, então faça uma descrição completa do
imóvel e não só do imóvel, de tudo
aquilo que tem ao redor do imóvel, se
aquele imóvel está perto de comércio, transporte, o
que tem ao redor daquele imóvel que pode
atrair compradores, faça um anúncio com boas fotos
também, existem anúncios que você não consegue nem
visualizar o interior do imóvel, mostre o seu
imóvel o máximo possível, características do imóvel, estado
de conservação do imóvel, se você optar por
realizar seu próprio anúncio, faça um anúncio atrativo,
não coloque só o básico que todo mundo
coloca, bote informações completas do imóvel, do arredor
do imóvel e com boas fotos.
Muita gente me pergunta o que eu acho
sobre realizar obra em imóvel, bom, primeiro você
deve ter em mente que quem arbitra o
preço de um imóvel é o mercado, então
nada garante que se você gastar 30 mil
reais numa reforma de um apartamento, os 30
mil reais ou mais vão voltar para você,
nada garante que o imóvel vai valorizar naquela
mesma proporção, então eu não sou fã de
grandes obras, eu acho que a gente tem
que realizar obras necessárias que existam no apartamento,
então isso que pode ser necessário pode ser
desde o básico como só uma pintura, é
importante que você deixe o apartamento limpo para
causar uma boa impressão a todo mundo que
vai visitar e o primeiro passo para isso
é que as paredes estejam pintadas, além disso
é recomendado que você pinte as paredes de
branco, porque o branco ele traz uma sensação
de amplitude, além da sensação de limpeza, então
essa sensação de amplitude causada por paredes brancas
é melhor do que a sensação de paredes
escuras que fazem com que o imóvel pareça
menor do que ele realmente é, além da
pintura você deve realizar outros consertos estéticos que
possam existir naquele apartamento, vamos supor que você
arrematou um apartamento, em algum banheiro está faltando
um revestimento de uma parede, deixar aquilo sem
revestimento vai causar uma sensação ruim em quem
está visitando aquele imóvel, porque parece que o
imóvel está muito deteriorado, então faça essas pequenas
correções, mas tenha em mente que você não
deve gastar muito em obras, primeiro você vai
botar o imóvel a venda por um preço
abaixo do preço do mercado, porque seu objetivo
é vender rápido, realizar o lucro rápido e
quem sabe arrematar mais imóveis, então essa venda
rápida com preço abaixo do mercado já é
um atrativo para que a pessoa compre o
imóvel e possa utilizar esse valor de desconto
que você está oferecendo na venda para que
ela mesmo realize sua própria obra e deixe
o imóvel da maneira que lhe convém, afinal
gosto é sempre muito relativo, eu posso achar
algum tipo de piso lindo e pode ser
que você ache esse mesmo piso horrível, então
não adianta você gastar muito porque pode ser
que a pessoa não tenha interesse naquele tipo
de obra que você fez, mas você sim
deve realizar consertos estéticos para deixar o apartamento
apresentável, isso pode se resumir a uma simples
pintura ou alguns outros consertos estéticos, vou dar
um exemplo aqui de um apartamento muito antigo,
caso você arremate um apartamento muito antigo e
aquele apartamento não passou por obra recente, ele
provavelmente vai estar com um piso, um revestimento
em cozinha e um banheiro que não é
mais o padrão utilizado hoje em dia, então
nesse caso é interessante sim que você realize
uma pequena obra para deixar aquilo um pouco
mais moderno, mas você não precisa usar o
material mais caro do mundo que exista, basta
que você deixe o imóvel apresentado, essa questão
de realizar obra de conservação ou não é
também algo que você deve considerar no momento
pré-leilão, porque muitas vezes no leilão pode
ser que você não tenha nenhuma informação sobre
o estado de conservação daquele imóvel, que você
não tenha conseguido fotos internas daquele imóvel ou
nenhuma informação com porteiro, síndico, vizinho, nada do
tipo, então você já deve considerar previamente o
valor de uma pequena obra, e como você
vai estimar isso?
Você pode ir a um site de lojas
maiores de materiais de construção que existam na
sua cidade e realizar a busca de qual
é o preço médio de um piso, por
exemplo, e aí você pode calcular ali, na
sua cidade o preço médio fica em torno
de 40 reais o metro do piso que
você acha ok, e aí vamos supor que
esse imóvel específico é um apartamento de 60
metros, você considerar ali que você vai gastar
40 reais um metro quadrado e esse apartamento
tem 60 metros, você gastaria de piso, de
material, 2.400 reais, aí você gastaria um
pouco mais, porque tem argamassa, tem outros materiais
necessários para realizar uma obra, mas vamos arredondar
esse valor de 2.400 para 3.000,
considerando que você vai gastar esses outros materiais
também necessários além do piso, já faça previamente
uma pesquisa com um profissional, um pedreiro, para
saber quanto é que ele cobraria de mão
de obra para reformar todo o piso de
um apartamento de 60 metros, e aí pode
ser que ele te fale, que isso aí
vai custar 2.000, 3.000 reais, e
aí você já tem uma noção que com
6.000 reais você consegue deixar aquele apartamento
zero bala, porque quando você troca o piso
de um apartamento inteiro, você deixa aquele apartamento
zerado, vai ficar esteticamente bonito e o imóvel
vai ficar novo, então você vai fazer isso
com um pouco mais 6.000 reais para
um apartamento aí de 60 metros nesse nosso
exemplo aqui, então é importante que você calcule
isso também, agora grandes projetos, coisas muito caras,
realmente acho que não tem sentido, primeiro que
acho que o grande objetivo de todo mundo
que participa de um leilão com a finalidade
de investimento é ter o retorno financeiro, o
lucro o mais rápido possível, então é interessante
que você conceda o desconto, e segundo, que
grandes reformas não te garantem que o imóvel
vai valorizar naquela mesma medida, porque quem dita
o valor do imóvel é o mercado, então
nada garante que se você gastar ali 100
.000 reais no imóvel, o mercado vai considerar
que seu imóvel valorizou em 100.000 ou
mais, nada te garante isso, realmente recomendo que
você não faça grandes reformas.